thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
making this video possible
to see exclusive content around this
video check out my page
on nebula the voyages of the starship
enterprise d
are some of the most iconic pieces of
science fiction
ever made and star trek the next
generation
contains some of the greatest episodes
of sci-fi tv
ever and some stinkers but we don't talk
about those
it also contains a vast array of planets
in total 425 planets feature in the
series
but of those only 154 are actually shown
on screen
on screen that's dr hannah wakeford
lecturer in astrophysics at the
university of bristol
in this video hannah and i will go
through the planet shown in star trek
tng the tv series only mind you not the
films to work out which ones could
really exist
according to the known laws of planetary
science i'm not enthusiastic about this
plan
we've previously done this four planets
in star wars the mcu
and warhammer 40 000 but this time
there's a difference
i'm sorry star trek but your planets
suck
how dare you she's right we're not
saying that the planets shown in tng
are wrong they're just very samey and
boring
we've gone through all 154 planets shown
in tng
and found that there are perhaps 19 that
are actually
interesting those are the ones that
we'll talk about in this video but
they'll be representative of most of the
other planets
there are a couple of reasons for why
tng is so unimaginative in the planets
it depicts but
we'll get to those later we've divided
up the planets depicted into
four very rough categories terrestrial
planets
ice giants gas giants and those that are
otherwise
uncharacterizable we've got a lot of
planets to get through
armed with all the information from the
show and the official sources available
online
and hannah and his phds it's time to
take a voyage
among the starts make it so
first the series of gas giants that the
show depicts despite making up an
estimated
30 percent of all planets more massive
than saturn discovered so far in the
galaxy
there are only nine gas giants of
approximately saturn size and above
shown in all of star trek the next
generation that's less than six percent
of all planets
pentarus three is kind of interesting
setting a story on a
desert moon of a gas giant not
dissimilar to mars but with a breathable
atmosphere
most of the others seem entirely
plausible being similar to our solar
system's own
jupiter and saturn but the really
interesting planets here are detria
ii and detria-6 and that's because they
collide birth of a new star
the enterprise will hold position until
the gravitational instability subsides
that we can get in for a closer look
this is a really cool idea and there's
some basis in fact but unfortunately
while gas giants and stars are made out
of the same material
hydrogen and helium the difference is
quantity
it would take around 80 jupiters coming
together into a planet before it would
have enough mass to start hydrogen
fusion at its core and become a star
if a gas giant becomes large enough at
about 13 times the mass of jupiter
it can become what is called a brown
dwarf what some people call a failed
star
these are actually large enough to fuse
deuterium into helium 3 in their cores
which is kind of a precursor to hydrogen
fusion for at least some of their lives
and though they may sometimes look like
planets or stars
they are a distinct mass transition
between the two making up their own
category of fascinating astrophysical
objects
for the two planets in the detria system
to combine into a star the larger planet
would have to be
just on the cusp of having enough mass
to start hydrogen fusion
and therefore be a brown dwarf rather
than a planet which it certainly
looks like but there's a problem
time if these objects were to collide
and form a star
and that's a big if assuming there's
enough mass between the two
the result would not be what's depicted
firstly the result would be a puny star
maybe
a tenth the size of the sun assuming
detrio ii is about the size of jupiter
which would burn a mere two and a half
thousand kelvin less than half the
temperature of the sun
and secondly more importantly the
process would take an
age likely tens of thousands of years to
start the hydrogen fusion after the
collision of the objects
not mere hours so both time
and mass are against this happening as
depicted and sadly that means
it's not possible damn you
also related to the gas giants are the
ice giants
there are two of these in the series
neptune in our solar system and
tethys 3 which appears to be basically
neptune again in case you were wondering
the difference between ice giants and
gas giants is that while gas giants like
jupiter and saturn
are mostly made of hydrogen and helium
ice giants like neptune and uranus
while still mostly hydrogen and helium
contain a significant amount of heavier
compounds
like water ammonia and methane like the
name suggests some of this will be in
the form of ice crystals high in the
atmosphere but it's more likely that
beneath the clouds on these planets
there's actually a planet-wide ocean of
supercritical fluid
this is a state of matter where material
at high temperature and high pressure
behaves a bit like a gas and a bit like
a liquid
tefl3 is described as having a frozen
helium core
meaning that it would be solid the core
of the planet would be under incredible
pressure keeping it hot
meaning that actually it should be a
supercritical fluid
so tefl3 couldn't exist as described
we'll bang in the only two planets we
couldn't otherwise categorize here
of which only rousseau 5 was interesting
which is where wesley takes his
shape-shifter girlfriend on the holodeck
in season two's the dofa
i'll let wesley explain in a moment the
harmonic resonance
from the neutrino clouds will become
synchronous
it's so beautiful this is pretty much
technobabble
neutrinos are fundamental particles that
have no charge
pretty much no mass and pass through
normal matter like it isn't there and
the idea of them causing
sound in a vacuum no less is
completely wrong rousseau 5 definitely
couldn't exist as it's shown
i hate this it is revolting more
please russo 5 is about as strange as
the planets in tng got and you have to
give the writers some credit for trying
it's nothing compared to say the worlds
of the mcu but it's a lot more
imaginative than normally depicted
in fact every other planet in the series
that we haven't mentioned so far
is terrestrial meaning earth-like
planets
it's frankly really boring of course
the reason for there being so many
earth-like planets is that it made
filming the show
a whole lot easier star trek was
predominantly shot in what's called the
30 mile zone in
and around hollywood which as tom scott
has made a video about
was where union negotiated pay was
cheaper being defined as
local so a lot of the planets ended up
looking very similar but
what if that wasn't an issue what if
budget and location didn't matter and we
could set a story on
whatever planet we wanted well that's
exactly what we did
here's an episode of star trek tng that
features an actually
interesting scientifically accurate
planet illustrated by elizabeth
fierkovsky
captain's log stardate 4408 7.9
the enterprise is on route from gerald 5
to helya 3
transferring the last known population
of critically endangered corporate birds
for safe keeping at a breeding center
the boy
young wesley crusher has volunteered to
care for the birds
on route we have received a distress
call from the federation starbase on
crowdfeud 5867h
requesting immediate evacuation
picardenreiker discussed the upcoming
evacuation riker says that a large comet
has entered the crow feud system and has
a trajectory that will directly
impact the science station monitoring
the planet's upper atmosphere
on arriving at the planet they'll have
about half an hour to evacuate
federation people and material
riker says this won't be enough time to
use transporters so volunteers to take
their shuttles down to the space station
picard agrees make it so he says
meanwhile a huge dirty ball of rock and
ice
bears down on the station
next up the earth-like terrestrial
planets we've crudely subdivided these
based on their color
barren planets red planets brown planets
gray planets blue planets and green
planets
compared to other sci-fi universes it's
really quite
dull but there are some interesting
planets in here
none of the six barren planets are
particularly interesting one of them's
just mercury and the rest seem plausible
but
three of the 20 red planets are pretty
cool
like for example titanic's b and dalet
iv tadly locked planets
[Music]
tidally locked planets are some of my
favorite exoplanets
where the rotation period of the planet
matches the time taken
to orbit its star this results in one
side of the planet being baking hot
while the other side
languishes frozen in darkness this
sounds like it should be a rare
occurrence
but in fact most of the exoplanets we've
discovered today have been tidally
locked to their stars
ditalix b from season one episode
conspiracy
is actually a pretty great example of a
tidally locked
planet temperatures reach 180 degrees
celsius on the day side and
mines were established in the temperate
zones between that scorching day side
and the frozen night side
we've actually observed a similar planet
kepler-42d
about 170 light years away it's about
the size of mars and has a dayside
temperature of 180 centigrade
though we don't know if this planet has
an atmosphere or not italics b could
definitely exist though
dalheid4 another planet from the dofa is
a bit more involved dalid4 rotates only
once per revolution
one might surmise the two hemispheres
have developed disparate cultures which
is a major cause of most wars
we would expect very different species
and civilizations to evolve on either
side of the planet where the conditions
are completely different
in fact the civil war could probably
only take place on the terminator
because depending on the evolutionary
differences it would be hard for them to
survive on either side
they would never have had to event the
light bulb on the day side for example
on the night side they might have had
large eyes and light skins
if vitamin d didn't come in their diet
to be tidally locked you'll be very
close to your star
depending on the mass of the star which
you can approximate from its color
we could work out how big it would look
in the sky there would likely be very
fast winds driving the upper atmosphere
which would make communication difficult
like they said here
so in short seems possible the final
interesting red planet in the series is
onara this
basically appears to be earth but red
and it's pretty similar to a couple of
other planets like relver 7 and
moab 4. there's two possibilities with
planets like these
either the planet is red due to some
compound like iron oxide being prevalent
in its crust
or its star is small and cool outputting
a lot of
red light that causes the vegetation on
the planets to be largely red
plants on iaf are green because of
chlorophyll a pigment that enables
photosynthesis quite why plants evolved
to use chlorophyll in this way isn't
exactly clear
but one theory is that early plants
needed to balance absorbing enough
energy to survive
but not so much energy that they
overheated in the process which would
denature their delicate proteins
it turns out that the intensity of
starlight that reaches the earth's
surface
peaks in the green part of the spectrum
and so by being green
hence reflecting green light early
plants reflected enough energy to
prevent
overheating if this is correct then
plants on a planet around a cooler star
emitting more red wavelengths of light
would evolve to be
red maximizing reflected light while
still absorbing enough
to photosynthesize either through this
mechanism or
just boring old iron oxide these red
planets seem possible
there are four mostly grey terrestrial
planets in the series
all of which are very boring and seem
quite possible are you starting to see
why we put off this video for so
long but what's minorly more interesting
than gray
brown there are 27 brownish terrestrial
planets in tng
and some of these are actually
interesting like for example
basalis three this is a planet that has
its surface
ravaged by firestorms every seven years
firestorm can take up winds of over 200
kilometers per hour
and temperatures as high as 300 degrees
c they form
when solar flare radiation reacts with
high-energy plasma present in the
planet's atmosphere
this appears to be the result of a
seven-year solar cycle without bursts of
radiation reacting with plasma that's
always present in the planet's upper
atmosphere
this could potentially happen if say the
planet is directly on the equatorial
plane of the star
not inclined to the plane like for
example most comets are or in fact the
earth is
we certainly see regular cycles of
activity from our sun
though not as dramatic as this however
real solar cycles aren't so sudden they
don't roar into life for a brief period
and then quiet down completely for
several years
they're much more gradual and further
the amount of energy required to heat
the atmosphere as depicted in the show
is astronomical
and would definitely strip the
atmosphere off the planet entirely
rather than causing localized firestorms
i'm ruling that basales 3
couldn't exist another interesting
planet in this category
is rana 4. being the home of
my name is kevin oxbridge you may
remember me from that time i killed all
the hush knock
everywhere my planet is rather normal
looking
and of course being a dowd i could make
it look however i want
the soil is a brownie purple kind of
color which i accomplished by making the
surface out of
metallic rock like glaucophane but
weekly
i could have made the soil rich in
metals that's oxidized in purple colors
like hematite
anyway i must get going to find a
punishment to fit my crime
so uh yeah thanks kevin that one's
possible
tartanin 3 is a planet that seems
perpetually dark and dusty
and seems to have a thick atmosphere the
wiki lists it as being
in perpetual twilight which isn't
correct twilight is when the sun is
below the horizon but still
illuminating the sky an atmosphere that
was thick in particulates
say from lots of volcanic activity or
fires or sandstorms would result in a
low diffuse light at the surface on the
dayside which is what we seem to see
what i find a lot more puzzling is what
data says
about a shuttle heading towards the
planet he will reach an atmospheric
interface of an altitude of 210
kilometers
there isn't really such a thing as an
atmospheric interface there is
no one boundary between the atmosphere
and outer space
i actually made a whole video about this
a planet's atmosphere exponentially
decreases in density with altitude and
the start of the vacuum of space really
depends on what your definition of
vacuum
is the most relevant boundary when
discussing a craft flying through the
atmosphere
is the carmen line above which an
aircraft is kept aloft
more by the centrifugal yes i do mean
centrifugal
force of its orbit than by any lift
provided by the surrounding atmosphere
the height of the carbon line is then
determined by the density
of the atmosphere on earth the common
line is at approximately 100 kilometers
above the surface
so for a common line to be at 210
kilometers in altitude
the atmosphere of tartan 3 would have to
be incredibly thick
i'm assuming it's made of the same stuff
as earth's atmosphere mostly nitrogen
and oxygen
because you know the crew breathe on the
planet this would produce
a colossal atmospheric pressure at the
surface far
greater than what we see in the show so
for this reason i'm actually going to
say that tar challenge 3 doesn't make
sense but that's more because of sloppy
writing than
anything else damn the final planet in
this category is boral 2
which is losing its atmosphere the
planet's atmosphere is dissipating sir
intense plasmonic reactions are
destroying it the stratosphere is
already breaking down
there is very little detail to go on
here it sounds like the atmosphere has
just decided to peace out and escape to
space
if i had to guess i'd have to say that
the upper atmosphere is being ionized
potentially by some extraordinary solar
event and this is causing what we call
charge exchange escape this is where a
fast moving
ion captures an electron from a
slow-moving atom in the atmosphere
which creates a fast-moving atom with no
net electric charge
and a slow moving ion the fast-moving
atom
then escapes the gravitational pull of
the planet leaving behind the ion
if this were to happen on a vast scale
with huge sections of the atmosphere
being ionized by some
cataclysmic burst of solar activity then
loss of an entire atmosphere
could potentially happen but this is
right at the edge of how we understand
planetary
atmospheres and how they can dissipate
on such large scales
but going back to our story there's
atmospheric shenanigans going on
too jordy and ryker are coordinating the
rapid evacuation of the science station
around crawfowd when they receive word
from the enterprise
data informs the away team that the
comet has experienced some unexpected
outgassing as it neared the planet's
star the force of steam and other
compounds escaping due to solar heating
has altered the comet's trajectory to
the other side of the planet the space
station no longer needs evacuating
geordie and riker are joined by the
relieved station's head scientist who
invites them to stay
and observe the comet impact on the
other side of the planet
well commander jordy says we can stay
for a couple of hours these
opportunities don't come up very often
so they accept she leads them over to a
science panel and explains that the
atmosphere on crawfowd is interesting
the planet itself is an example of a
warm neptune
tidally locked to its star with its
atmosphere being evaporated
by its extreme proximity the atmosphere
itself contains an interesting mix of
silicates iron and magnesium the impact
of the comet will produce
interesting atmospheric effects that
they can monitor here
geordi is very interested riker not so
much
meanwhile wesley is struggling to keep a
hold of his coffee at birds
they keep following him and trying to
escape his quarters
when data appears at the door to ask
questions about poetry
the birds all attempt to leave one
dashes through the rapidly closing door
wesley chases the bird through the
corridors down to engineering
and the bird leaps with all of its might
attempting to jump directly into the
warp core
but wesley catches it just in time what
were you doing
wesley asked the bird you could have
been killed
back on the science station geordie
reicher and the head scientist
watch on the station's consoles as the
comet impacts into the planet
clouds of magnesium silicate billow up
from the impact
shock waves echo around the planet's
atmosphere it's
spectacular to watch however something's
wrong
cloud formation is far stronger than
expected the comet penetrated
far deeper into the atmosphere than they
thought possible the head scientist says
going so deep into the atmosphere has
kicked up seed particles that generated
a colossal front of lightning storms
this
cascading storm courtesy of the strong
planetary jet is now heading for the
space station at
breakneck speed jordy starts organizing
an even hastier evacuation
riker squints into commercial
[Music]
we've been pretty hard in this video on
the writers of star trek for being quite
unimaginative in what planets they
describe and we've already talked about
the limitations of budget stopping them
from showing anything much more
interesting than
well california but something else we
had to remember is that this show was
written in the early 90s
at the start of the 90s the existence of
planets outside of our solar system
orbiting other stars was still very much
in the realm of science fiction it was
not until the mid-90s that
big breakthroughs linking stars and
planets was made with the discovery of
the first brown dwarf
the same year the first exoplanet
orbiting a sun-like star
was also discovered however both of
these were still something of an oddity
not even thought of by the great
roddenberry the first planet was a hot
jupiter
a jupiter-sized world tidally locked to
its star where a year takes just five
days
the first brown dwarf showed methane in
its atmosphere something only previously
measured in the atmospheres of saturn
and its moon titan but it also showed
that it was fusing
elements at its core so not a planet at
all so while tng was made at the dawn of
these discoveries we can forgive the
writers for thinking they may still be a
little
too bizarre to frame an episode around
being the most similar to earth
the most common category of planets on
the show was the terrestrial blue
planets there are 66 of these of the 156
planets in total and only a couple that
are actually interesting
one of them was kalon 2. oh no
this is a luxar episode
son is dying transforming from a yellow
dwarf into a red
giant if this happened it was expected
that the star would destroy or at least
irradiate the planet depending on how
far away the planet is from its star
there are several things that can happen
when a star becomes a red giant
in a distant orbit a planet doesn't
experience much change at all perhaps in
the change in the spectrum of the
starlight it receives
a bit closer in near to where the star
will expand the planet will experience a
change in orbit
this is because the star loses mass in
the process of becoming a red giant
its outer layers being ejected into
space this scenario is what we think
will happen to both earth and mars when
our sun turns into a red giant about
five and a half billion years from now
pushed out
to more distant orbits closer again to
the star
and things get decidedly dicier for a
planet
inside the envelope of a star's
expansion a planet will also experience
a change in orbit
but its atmosphere will likely be
stripped away by the strong plasma
currents in the outer layers of the star
the planet wouldn't be habitable anymore
but that's still better than planets
that start in very
close orbits they would just get
absorbed into the star and
they're never coming out that's the
death of a planet
it sounds like the writers are imagining
the third scenario here with the planet
being absorbed in the star's upper
atmosphere
in reality the time it takes for a star
to become a red giant is on the order of
a few hundred
million years with most of the action
taking place in the final few million
years
but who has the time to sit around and
wait for that to happen so while the
scenario is good
the timeline is not so i say not
possible
i'll go check the pattern buffers the
planet katan
is a similar story to this but a bit
further down the line
in one of the best episodes of trek
captain picard learns how to play the
flute
gets into tie-dye and sees the dying
days of a world
caught in the sights of its star going
by hannah's categories earlier
this appears to be a category 3 planet
engulfed by the low-density outer
atmosphere of the expanding
star we learned that the star actually
goes nova subsequently and the events
that captain picard sees
happened a thousand years ago the nova
which in simple terms is when a star
explodes is the issue here
there are a few possibilities we can
rule out what we call an instant
supernova which is where the star's core
collapses all in one go
because the star is yellow and not hot
and blue as would be required for this
instant supernova
far more likely is that instead of just
one star picard was actually observing a
binary system of a white dwarf
and a main sequence star the white dwarf
siphoned mass away from the main
sequence star to the point where it was
ready to explode in a nova
this is relying on how few details are
supplied in the episode and lots of
particular circumstances but if we run a
million or so simulations
we might be able to make something like
the events of katan happen
so i'm going to say just about possible
[Applause]
odette 9 is a bluish planet that we only
see briefly at the start of season two
and we only bring it up because it's
purple and
that's kind of cool purple skies seem
incredibly sci-fi and alien
but could definitely exist an atmosphere
with plenty of iodine gas or phosphorus
would be purple but those are both
highly reactive so wouldn't last in the
atmosphere for long
however we sometimes see purple skies
here on earth
typically preceding hurricanes or
typhoons when the extreme amount of
vertical motion in these
storms sucks salt crystals up into the
air from the oceans beneath
leading to more atmospheric scattering
the same process that causes the sky to
be blue
just a lot more intense perhaps the crew
the enterprise just so happens to arrive
at odette 9 at a time when the
atmosphere was
super saturated in this way maybe due to
a seasonal cycle
something that we hope we don't see on
earth anytime soon are the events of
penthara 4.
right strap in because this one is very
convoluted
first of all the planet is struck by an
asteroid this kicks up a bunch of dust
that blocks out the sun
so much sunlight is blocked out that
irradiance decreases by 80 percent
this results in a predicted nuclear
winter with global average temperatures
expected to plummet by 10 to 12 celsius
so the colony on the planet asks the
enterprise to draw some holes in the
planet to release carbon dioxide that
the planet previously didn't want to
release
to cause a greenhouse effect this works
reversing the cooling of effect but the
phaser drilling then causes a bunch of
tectonic activity including the collapse
of the mantle around the boar
site so the resulting volcanic activity
then causes more materials to be added
to the atmosphere which then increases
cloud cover causing another nuclear
winter so the enterprise
ionizes the volcanic material in the
atmosphere with a phaser
turning it into a plasma which was then
absorbed by the enterprise's
shields and ejected into space and and
in the end the planet's climate
stabilizes
i think a bunch of geophysical stuff
here doesn't make any
sense that's nowhere near enough
drilling to release enough co2 to
counteract the cooling
20 holes drilled into the mantle
wouldn't destabilize an entire planet
but the main takeaway here is don't [ __ ]
with the climate
geoengineering is dangerous planet's not
possible
the final blue planet is atreya 4 which
is also experiencing some tectonic
problems namely
its core solidifying our gravitational
field has been affected
seismic activity is increased by a
factor of three
if the cooling continues at this rate a
trio will become
uninhabitable in 13 months there is
precedent for planetary cause to
solidify that's what we think might have
happened to mars
and it could certainly cause tectonic
activity by shrinking in size as it
solidified
putting stress on the mantle and crust
but what doesn't make sense
is the expected change in gravitational
field magnetic field would make much
more sense we think that mars lost its
planetary magnetic field or
magnetosphere
when it's core partly solidified the
earth's liquid core is what produces our
magnetosphere protecting us from the
solar wind
what also doesn't make sense is how fast
the core is solidifying
this is a process that would take
millions of years and the idea of a
planetary course solidifying to the
point of destroying the magnetosphere in
just a year or two
is absolutely out of the question you'll
notice that
tng does this a lot they compress their
time in order to make for exciting
stories
unfortunately they that comes at the
cost of scientific accuracy
a tree of four doesn't make sense that
just leaves the green
terrestrial planets and our final three
interesting ones of the 17
in this category and we've saved the
best till last
these three planets are certainly
something first up
is theta eight there are three
impossibilities in this clip
see if you can spot them surface
temperature minus 291 degrees celsius
winds up to 312 meters per second
but i have found indications of debris
in an elliptical orbit
did you catch them the most obvious is
the temperature which geordi says is
minus 291 degrees celsius
that's below absolute zero and so
definitely impossible
the other two are more subtle firstly
the age of the planet
the okudagram here lists its ages 72
billion
years which is five times older than the
age of the universe
so unless there's some major changes in
cosmological theory in the next few
hundred years
that's impossible too the last
impossibility is the mass
listed as 4.35 trillion tons
that sounds like a lot but it's less
than one trillionth
the mass of the earth it's about the
same mass as
methane a tiny moon of saturn
approximately three kilometers across
the fact is that planets are huge the
numbers describing their masses are
quite
literally astronomical a mass on the
order of trillions of tons is
far far too small to match the planet as
depicted
i will say one positive thing about the
planet though the wind speeds
makes sense 312 meters per second is
about half the wind speed we see on
neptune the strongest winds in our solar
system
so that's pretty cool oh and there's a
hotel and a bubble on the surface
and it's one of the weirder episodes
overall but yeah this this planet is
impossible our penultimate planet is
oh no it's subrosa
beverly it's all right have trusted me
this is possibly the worst episode of
the entire series
although there are some strong
contenders but none of them have dr
crusher falling in love with the lamp
and it centers on the planet
caldos this is a strange planet
terraformed
and has a weather control system
installed to make the entire northern
hemisphere look like
scotland complete with bad accents just
dinner light that candle
why not it'll bring the ghost we've
touched on the problems of having
uniform climates across a planet before
in our video on warhammer 40k
but caldos is slightly different to say
tanith
because what makes scotland scottish in
terms of its climate
i don't mean the fantastic landscapes
highly variable food and top drawer
people we can classify climates using
what's called the kurpen
geiger system based on precipitation and
temperature
in this scotland comes out as f b or
temperate oceanic climate for the entire
northern hemisphere of caldos to be
similarly classified
it would need a uniformly temperate
temperature
and pretty much no difference in
rainfall year
round as with tanith you'd need to
introduce a strong meridional
circulation to evenly distribute heat
across the planet
and you'd also need to introduce a lot
of moisture that could be evenly
spreading out large locks
or diverting water vapour transport from
the southern hemisphere which
could be an ocean but the fact that
they've only done this to one
hemisphere makes this so much less
likely
atmospheric processes are symmetric
about the equator
so for one hemisphere to be so totally
different to the other
without orbital shenanigans just doesn't
make
sense and i know there's a weather
manipulation network on caldos but
that can't create moisture out of
nothing it basically works like magic
in the show and for that reason i'm
gonna say it couldn't exist
if only this episode didn't that just
leaves our final planet
tagra four and this is really a
existential one they've managed to
pollute their atmosphere pretty badly
it's amazing to think that they go to
such lengths to clean the air instead of
regulating the emissions that cause the
problem
what if we let the industrial revolution
levels of coal burning continue
what if we didn't reduce our reliance on
fossil fuels what if we didn't realize
that cfcs were destroying the ozone
layer
what if we let civilization continue to
ruin our atmosphere with no resistance
well we would be screwed no correct that
we're screwed now
we would be completely and utterly lost
do not pass go do not collect 200 pounds
well the planet would survive just look
at venus that planet's fine the planet's
still there
what it is is a life-destroying event
not just our lives but the lives of most
organisms on the planet
far too real star trek take it back the
actual content of this episode is far
less interesting than the premise it's
mostly about a reactor on the planet
that strip pollutants from the
atmosphere and needs the help of a cube
to stabilize it
there's obviously parallels here with
the earth's own anthropogenic climate
change
stressing the importance of the issue as
john de lancie doesn't actually have q
powers to fix everything so we'd need to
do it
ourselves but to us at least this
episode is interesting because it asks
what if we only discovered climate
change
too late you can make a very strong
argument that some
measure of industrialization is
necessary to discover climate change
you need certain materials to make
measurements of atmospheric pollutants
and an extreme concentration of wealth
and expertise to derive the underlying
theory of radiative forcing
perhaps we are lucky that we discovered
climate change as early as we did
or then again perhaps the inhabitants of
tagra4
also discovered the issue early but
didn't think it was important enough to
fix
thank goodness our world would never do
something so stupid
in short the planet seems eerily
possible
so in summary of the 19 interesting
planets featured in star trek the next
generation
we think eight are possible leaving 11
in the realms of fiction
overall that means that 143 of the 154
planets shown
are probably possible which is a pretty
great track record
but it would be fair to say they play
things very
safe i would have loved to have seen
some more tidy lock planets more ice
giants more
exotic atmospheres and fewer brown grey
blue california-based planets well
hannah
funny you should mention that and now
the conclusion wesley uses his
communication badge to tell geordi about
the birds trying to throw themselves
into the warp court
jordy replies that he has bigger
problems to deal with right now kid
wesley's confused goes to a computer
terminal and learns about what's
happening down on the planet
jordy tells riker that atmospheric
disruption from the comet impact has
made evacuation by shuttle impossible
there's just too much turbulence
the storms will be here in under an hour
reicher
orders the enterprise to start
transporting people off the station back
on the bridge
data tells him that that won't be enough
time to evacuate everyone
riker replies that he'll be the last
person off the station
at that moment wesley arrives on the
bridge he rushes to tell the captain
shut up wesley no no no captain i can
save the crew on the station
wesley explains the storm is made of
magnesium silica particles
but in traveling through craft feud's
atmosphere they will have picked up some
iron
if the enterprise shot a beam of highly
charged particles near the storm
they will generate a strong magnetic
field diverting the storm front because
of the accumulated iron making the
clouds magnetic
make it so mr data says picard the
enterprise shoots a glowing beam of
particles
into the atmosphere which already reads
off from a terminal
that the storms have been successfully
diverted away from the station
how did you think of that was it was the
birds
they were being confused by the magnetic
field produced by the warp core on the
enterprise i think they were trying to
migrate
so when i learned that the storm front
likely contained iron compounds i
thought we could do the same thing
and divert the clouds with a magnetic
field well mr crusher
says picard straightening his uniform at
least one of my officers isn't
bird-brained
hannah and i had a lot of fun putting
together this episode within
the episode as it gave us a chance to
depict a type of planet that's common in
the universe but
never seen on screen if you'd like to
hear us talk through the science behind
craft feud as well as watch the whole
episode without the bits in between
that's available over on my nebula page
as you've probably heard before
nebula is the streaming platform run by
a bunch of educational youtubers we all
have a say in how the site is run
and we all share in the revenue
generated by subscription fees in
exchange for paying for a subscription
to the site
not only do you get access to a bunch of
exclusive content from your favorite
youtubers early access to their videos
and
a lack of any adverts anywhere in or
around those videos
you also directly support original
content like
this without nebula i wouldn't have been
able to pay lizzie to do the beautiful
illustrations for this episode
but that's not all we've teamed up with
curiositystream who curate
and produce original ultra high quality
documentaries
if you like this video then you might
enjoy destination jupiter
about the findings of the juno mission
or hack the moon
about the engineers behind the apollo
program they have a huge
range of shows from space to philosophy
economics to medieval history
and we have a special deal with them
sign up to curiositystream at the link
below
and you also get access to nebula and if
you do say by the end of
may a 41 discount
that works out at less than a dollar a
month
and for that you get access to top
quality documentaries and small
indie productions like this one whenever
you want as well as directly supporting
creators
like me that's curiositystream.com
simon clark for an absolute bargain
thank you curiositystream for sponsoring
this video
thank you so much for watching the video
hannah and i were very reluctant to do
this one for reasons that have probably
become apparent by now
but i certainly hope that we've been
able to glean some pearls from the
pile of californian planets as always a
huge thanks to dr wakeford for helping
me out with this video
check out the link in the description to
her website where she talks about her
research but also other outreach
activities
thanks also must go to trustworthy
ginger
fusto samwise 2450 gabe and falcon acos
from the discord also linked below for
their help in categorizing the planets
in this video
hail claude and of course a huge thank
you to lizzy for drawing and animating
the episode within
this video definitely check out her
stuff in the description there's a link
to her instagram
i cannot get enough of her art style and
i docked out so
hard when she sent me the art for this
episode do let us know what you thought
in the comments below
both about the original episode but also
about the planets we talked about and
perhaps
didn't talk about did we skip over any
gems
let us know you know the drill of course
if you did enjoy the video please do pop
it a like
share it if you think might enjoy it and
if you'd like to see more like this
then you can subscribe but you can also
watch the previous videos in this series
about star wars the mcu and warhammer
40k
thank you again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one